[Musique]
pour de nombreux touristes new york
times square l'effervescence l'epasa les
chaînes de restaurants et de magasins
[Musique]
la traditionnelle congestion à quelques
coins de rue de là la toute nouvelle
attraction touristique
la sculpture qu'on surnomme le vaisseau
joyau d'un quartier qui vient de voir le
jour
at the new world esports classement
alliera tibet propriétaire d'un camion
de cuisine de rue il a vécu la
transformation depuis cinq ans de cet
ancien secteur désaffecté gratte ciel et
espace public on remplaçait piqueries et
refuges pour sans abri bat rappi pour
danoise d'efforts
[Musique]
hatsune york ces 25 milliards de dollars
d'investissements privés le plus
important projet immobilier de
l'histoire de new york l'équivalent de
25 terrains de football de superficie
pour usage commercial dans cinq tours à
bureaux des condos de luxe à 5 millions
de dollars chacun des parcs et espaces
publics puis un centre commercial de 7
étages on y retrouve des magasins de
luxe mais aussi des commerces
autrefois présent uniquement en ligne
dont macworld pour attirer les riches
milenio le côté ouest de méthane est en
pleine transformation depuis plusieurs
années déjà la conversion spectaculaire
dans cierra y en un parc surélever la
high line a changé le visage de ce
secteur tout comme la création du parc
rothen et l'utilisation de kits
commerciaux abandonnés
vient maintenant s'ajouter le quartier
haute saône young entièrement bâtie sur
une gare de triage encore en
exploitation
puisque c'est new york le quartier haute
saône ya aussi le sens de la démesure
sept autres gratte-ciel et une école
seront aussi construits d'ici quelques
années
cette transformation de la grosse pomme
a une saveur toute canadienne
l'entreprise related companies qui
pilote le projet est dirigé par le
canadien jack ross l'entreprise
partenaire pour le seigneur et oxford
properties groupe la division
d'investissement immobilier d'omers le
régime de pension des employés
municipaux de l'ontario oxford
properties groupe n'a pas voulu accorder
d'entrevue
mais s'il vient de connaître une de ses
meilleures années en 2018 grâce au
projet à 116 mais on compte aussi
beaucoup de détracteurs il affirme qu'il
s'agit d'un quartier construit sur
mesure pour les super riches
[Musique]
un espace commercial privé luxueux et
sans saveur déguisé en attraction
touristique grâce au vaisseau
[Musique]
les salles aussitôt passent ici chaque
mois elle croit que les petites
entreprises indépendantes des quartiers
avoisinants seront victimes du succès de
haute saône iods que leurs loyers
deviendra rapidement hors de prix ali
ratib lui espère que les 150 loyers
abordables promis dans le projet at the
news verront le jour mais surtout il
souhaite que les touristes continueront
d'affluer
[Musique]
c'est sa clientèle son gagne pain il a
choisi de miser sur le succès du
quartier hearts onions en s'établissant
ici jusqu'à maintenant tout semble lui
donner raison
et si philippe leblanc radio-canada new
york